the last chapter in the epilogue book
and you talk about coming home from
Guantanamo and talk about reception in
plants of the future how would you
rewrite those chapters today I don't
know that I would rewrite the chapters
about the epilogue in my book I finish
off saying that American justice in
Guantanamo is an oxymoron there are two
conflicting concepts the concept of
justice in Guantanamo I believe has not
been administered to any of the
prisoners they're not the ones that have
been released but the ones who have abs
corpus petitions pending in the US
courts nor the ones facing the US
military commissions so there wouldn't
be a great deal after six years to
rewrite and what would justice look like
them for those who have been released
well what happens when a person has been
falsely imprisoned imprisoned tortured
abused and their basic human rights
violated in any other circumstance they
are the people who did it are prosecuted
they are compensated they are given
access to medical psychological
treatment and there is a recognition in
the world that what will happen to these
people was wrong that has not happened
with the Guantanamo cases in any of the
cases every fight has been a fight to
the death in metaphorical terms nobody's
given an inch in terms of the
government's that were involved either
complicit Lee like the British
government or directly like the US
government and so we as the former
Guantanamo prisoners still carry the
stigma of being Guantanamo prisoners
when President Obama in 2009 it's one of
his first acts since coming into power
decided to sign the order essentially
closing with the aim of closing
Guantanamo Bay what was your reaction of
the time and were you hopeful or we did
you did you have a sense that that this
was not was physical was going to be
there are over the time when Obama came
into power and it actually made the
statements that he
close down Guantanamo he will stop the
secret detention sites and he will put
an end to torture I was actually touring
the UK at the time with a former
Guantanamo soldier a God who once served
there and both of us took this reaction
to say that it was too little too late
meaning that we had already seen on both
sides of the wire as it were the effects
of the bush policy to say that he was
going to close it was only reiterating
what what Bush himself had said several
times I would like to see the place
closed so it was nothing new it was as
they say in old wine in new bottles and
what we saw and what we've seen thus far
in the difference between obama and bush
is that Bush was the president who
ordered extrajudicial detention Obama is
the president who has ordered
extrajudicial killing and maintained the
extrajudicial detentions nothing has
changed greatly very few numbers
relatively speaking have been released
under Obama there are still over 171 /
171 prison still there with no
foreseeable end to their plight a more
personal level you talk about being away
from your family how were you able to
really adored were you able to reknit or
knit your relationship from your family
in reality Guantanamo has destroyed the
relationship that existed between family
members that's the putting it bluntly as
much as possible that going into too
much personal detail I think that's
happened across the board had happened
in my case and happen in the case of
many other people relationships that
have been built upon absolutely no
communication built upon fear and hope
and sadness and tears and then to come
home to see children that I've never
seen in some cases to see other children
who've grown up to the point that they
are no longer those young children to
step into the family where your position
is no longer recognized because those
roles have been filled
and there is no that this had never has
been a system by the British government
or the US government that has recognized
this aspect of of human life that is
simply shattered the relationships
between people men women children and
simply said well you were in Guantanamo
not even a sorry now you're back home
pick up your life that's your problem
now for me it was and I think for a lot
of the prisoners we didn't have these
support mechanisms that people that i
remember in guantanamo for example the
american soldiers had combat stress
which I we found sort of a bit laughable
because there was no combat there but
there's plenty of stress but we weren't
getting the counseling the soldiers were
getting the counseling so we returned
home to face life as it is a in addition
to being returned as Freeman we returned
to a post-911 world at post July the 7th
world in which Islamophobia was a key
factor and remains being to be a key
factor so we are now regarded as a fifth
column people who were born and raised
in this country are more English than
the English people themselves I've now
become this pariah community so in the
face and the light of all of that in
addition to being gone tanomo detainees
who by definition and default are
terrorism suspects and then try to build
a family life around that with the
children being attacked school sometimes
being called names sons of terrorists
children of terrorists how does one pick
up that who trains you for this who
teaches you how to deal with this nobody
and the only thing that we had as former
Guantanamo prisoners is our faith that
is what helped us in Guantanamo that is
what helped us through torture it is
what helped us in solitary confinement
and is what helps us now and in a world
where Islam is seen as the most
radicalizing factor the key that sparks
off all acts of terrorism this is a time
when our Islam is becoming stronger and
stronger so we reject this idea that
Islam
turns people towards terrorism but at
the same time what's happening right now
here we are being pushed into a
situation where we find that that is our
only refuge perhaps we could go back a
little bit back into back into the early
in your book you write quite a bit about
your involvement with the links gang in
Birmingham I wonder if you be you if I
could oh you to talk a little bit about
what it was like to grow up in a
multicultural setting plagued by at the
same time you know the politics of
racism and far-right movements and
perhaps compare that moment to what you
see now in the UK interesting my father
sent me to a Jewish school as a Muslim
kid so I was I was I was a minority in
the school that I went to I grew up
learning Hebrew and reading from the
Torah celebrating Chanukah pay second
poem and so forth and that was odd at
the time but it opened a door to me
which was one that helped me to
recognize other communities and in
record might help to recognize earlier
on the concept of persecuted or
criminalized communities so I had
friends who were not only Jewish but
also the area neighborhood where we
lived in initially there were a lot of
Irish people and they during the time
when I was growing up were the suspect
criminalized terrorist community because
what was happening in the north of
Ireland but growing up in in Britain
during that time when there was an
influx of immigrants from the South
Asian subcontinent had its own
difficulties and we were regarded as by
many from the far right at the time as
as people unwelcome we were attacked in
the street were beaten we were punched
and kicked and abused and we formed
little groups to defend ourselves and
one of them was called the links in
Birmingham and it was a multi multi
ethnic group which consisted of young
black Asian Arab and Irish kids who
simply wanted to
be teenagers together form themselves
into a gang and if you do no good but at
least to defend themselves against
racist we did everything else in any
other gang member i suppose does which
isn't something to be proud of but i
think it the one aspect of pride that we
did have and still after this day is
that we fought off the rightist racists
we we talked about you talk about
Islamophobia today and you talk about
your experiences growing as pakistani
indian what happens to young pakistani
kids today in england with that with
that change Islamophobia added to it so
there are there are groups there were
groups during when I was growing up who
identified as different ethnic groups in
different multi ethnic groups from the
afro-caribbean from the Irish and from
the Asian communities who are foreign
and were the disdain against them was
based upon the fact that they were the
foreign foreigners and xenophobia was it
was palpable what's different now today
is that you've got organisations who on
the basis of nationalism ultra
nationalism will say that we accept
these other groups of people as long as
they are integrated and assimilated but
groups like the Muslims and they've
specify the Muslim community cannot by
definition assimilate cannot become the
same as us in a robotic fashion and
therefore they are seen as a threat and
if you add to this the mix of foreign
policy if you add it to it the mix of
statements from the media and
politicians in relation to whether it's
the Muslim dress the Muslim eating
habits Muslim prayer rituals and so
forth then the atmosphere has been
created with open season on all thing
Muslims and so what we find out is that
they will say things like not all
Muslims are terrorists but ever eat
every terrorist is a Muslim which of
course is a lie
and not factually true but it feeds into
the sort of anti-islamic statements that
are being made all around the world
we r on asked you about how what it was
like to come back and your venue talked
about the difficulty in repairing family
relationships and your personal life in
come back what what what pushed you into
deciding to enter public life and to
write the book in Guantanamo did in
essence Guantanamo pushed me into
wanting to talk about these issues I
knew I realized from my discussions or
other interrogations from the American
interrogators that with the greatest of
respect a lot of these people really
didn't know what they were doing or what
world they were dealing with they had
perhaps been involved in dealing with
drug dealers in in New York or anywhere
else in the United States of America but
now they had come to countries whose
names they couldn't pronounce and talk
to people in languages they didn't know
existed and then suggests somehow that
they understood the psyche and the
mentality and the history and the
heritage and the knowledge of these
people where you had the cradles of
civilization and it seemed bizarre to me
that these people were now physically
and attempting to psychologically
dictate how the politics and the future
of this region will learn what will
ensue and so I think that having seen
what what they felt they were doing in
comparison to what they really were
doing it was important for me to start
to talk about and try to explain things
so am I my process of trying to explain
my process of campaigning as it were
began in Guantanamo it began in solitary
confinement in bag began in Bagram with
the interrogators with the CIA and with
the FBI and military intelligence and
also trying to advocate for the short
periods of time that I was able to do so
when I was not in solitary confinement
the rights of other prisoners the worst
thing I think that a person has to
endure in addition to or perhaps even
more than his own torture is witnessing
the abuse and torture of another person
in front of you and then remaining
silent or impotent to do anything about
it so that i think was for me the the
reason to to campaign and also
accountability we're living in a world
where everybody wants to hold everybody
else to account and say and point
fingers and we had plenty of fingers
pointed at us as former prisoners we
were accused of i was accused of
hundreds of things all sorts of
statements in because there was no
access to any legal recourse people
could say whatever they wanted and one's
detention would be based upon what
another person said not on evidence so
people often say after my return do you
think that mi5 and the intelligence
services are watching you and I turn
around and say actually I don't care
because I'm watching them and that's
part of our job part of the job of cage
prisoners is to record is to document
and then present to the legal
authorities to the judicial authorities
and to the police the actions of British
intelligence in the torture and the
complicity of torture in of their own
own citizens I received a very good
reception of the book both nationally
and internationally from the quarters
where I expected it to be so traditional
left-wing middle-of-the-road Press
reported well on the right wing the
far-right report on it in the way that I
expected them to well he doesn't say
anything about what the Americans say
this is completely contrary to the
Americans interet interrogators version
of events and so forth but I think that
the people who have read my book and it
has been translated into several
different languages
often feedback to me saying that are you
going to do another sequel to it and I
said well that it all depends if I get
taken back to content again what was
your reception in the Muslim community
as I expected the Muslim community has
been extremely sympathetic it's been
it's been widely and well received in
the Muslim community i received a couple
of years ago something that was called
the muslim writers award for best
published author that enter grades gave
of things i don't really it doesn't
really matter to me about these things
but i think what i managed to do with it
was too I knew that what I had to tell
was important and I knew that lots
people would listen and I wasn't my book
wasn't really geared to gain sympathy
from the Muslim community I knew the
Muslim community would be sympathetic by
default it was geared to introduce a
world that wasn't just about Guantanamo
it was all of the processes that led to
me being taken to kuantan and then
afterwards Guantanamo was simply three
years of my life but I 40 years old by
the time I read the book and all of
these things I felt it was important in
my little way to tell the story of one
person's experience and then after
author of the book could you talk a
little bit about how you came to be
involved with cage prisoners and you're
sort of early involvement with the
organization and then how you came to
take this world that you're in there um
one good thing that I hear about now is
that the prisoners in Guantanamo they
know about cage prisons they'll often
talk about and send messages to through
the lawyers and themselves direct to us
about us so but when i was in Guantanamo
I didn't know about cage prisoners at
that time cage prisoners were simply a
website and was a portal information
portal exclusively documenting the case
of the Guantanamo prisoners so when I
returned from Guantanamo I found myself
looking at the site every day which it
was Ben
updated in terms of its news and content
and wanting to find out about the latest
information about the prisons that I
left behind and there's a sense of guilt
of course for anyone who's freed from a
place like that is that you're free you
go and meet children of prisoners who
are still held there and you can't tell
them anything you can't say you can't
explain why you're free and why their
father isn't so I felt a sense of guilt
offender felt a sense of importance that
that it was an important task for me
because I could do it because I know
that I can speak and give the voice lots
of people would like to get out and I've
been entrusted by a lot of the prisoners
who tell me and if I felt that I was
doing something wrong I think they would
tell me but I made prisoners all around
the world former prisoners who endorsed
what I do and that gives me hope and
support and they are my advisory council
all these prisoners from around the
world they're my advisory council and I
seek the consultation in what I do and
what I do is to help this organization
cage prisoners become well known become
an authority become respected and become
a voice for those prisoners who have
learned and what just logistically in
what what what the cage prisoners look
like from the inside when you join or
did you join what was mechanism by Japan
I was regularly being contacted by the
organization to speak at their events to
talk about some of the experiences I had
seen and others and to be in contact
with them about other prisoners about
lawyers and networking I also built up a
prisoner network of people who were not
in Guantanamo in Bagram and secret
detentions and even here in the UK so I
had a lot of close contact with
prisoners for example here in the UK who
were held either under control orders or
under deportation orders extradition
orders or were held for example without
charge in UK prisons and all those who
were I believe unjustifiably convicted
or given extraordinarily long sentences
for crimes that will that were not
accrued not crimes just a couple of
years ago so all of that was part of how
I got involved in the organization is
talking about their cases and then
eventually after being so involved in
the mechanics of the organization I was
asked to join it officially by its board
members the organization was small when
I joined it it was as I said it was just
a website and every now and then they
did a few protests and they did some
events and some meetings and paintings
used to take places in people's houses
who were the figures who are involved in
it you're as an American I don't know
much about at the time I was a there
were volunteers there was one woman
who's a central figure of it who's no
longer with the organization but she was
a very central figure in terms of
uploading the content in terms of being
like almost a an Oracle of information
there was awesome Qureshi who was a
junior researcher at the time there was
a couple of doctors and a couple of
lawyers would help to set up the
organization but after I joined it
really moved into the public arena
became more of a campaign organization
and has moved along now to something
that's closer to a think tank then then
then I than just a campaign organization
but it is both and what would you well
over the summer were some of the early
projects that you're involved with once
you kind of move more centrally into the
the functioning of cage prison well
there were investigations taking place
into the disappeared so one of the early
reports i remember that i was in croatia
for example that written was was about
the ghost prisoners by people who've
been not who were unfortunate enough or
fortunate of depending how you look at
it not to be sent to Guantanamo and were
held in secret detention site so trying
to locate them became a for me or simple
of them became a personal matter because
some of them I'd known or known off and
had met their families and have
subsequently been in contact with them
and i'm still trying to in some cases
locate these disappeared individual of
whom it was widely reported that the
Americans had captured but now our
disappeared into black holes literally
so that was an important issue also
there was the issues regarding the
United Kingdom people I soon approached
me and said we know you're talking about
Guantanamo and we realize how difficult
that issue is but please also remember
us here in the UK because there are very
close similarities and also one thing
that was very important is that my work
a lot of my work took me to Northern
Ireland to meet with former prisoners
there with the primarily Republican
prisoners but also some loyalists and
then to talk to them about in tournament
and get feedback and information be
involved in seminars which made
comparisons between the experience of
the Irish and the Muslim community and
since that time until now I have some
very close Irish Republican friends do
you remember a conversation in
particular with any of these these these
yes the Republicans alone listen
absolutely and then there's one I I know
that is often said by a lot of the
Republican prisons and they say you know
mozem at least they'd wait until we
speak and make it here accents but with
you guys they see you coming off you
know a mile away and I said of course
that's true unless you happen to be a
you know indigenous Irish Muslim then
you're really screwed yeah as a
criminalized community as criminalized
communities what difference do you see
between the experience of the Irish and
the experience of Muslims in Britain now
or what country or what equally what
continuities when you say that because a
group called the continuity IRA but
that's a different matter the reality of
the two experiences was put to me quite
succinctly by my lawyer Gareth appears
in 1998 when she said to me mozem it was
the turn of the Irish for a period but
your next meaning the Muslim community
and she was right she'd predicted
something 1998 was the year of the omagh
bombing which was carried out I believed
by the real or the continuity IRA in 98
but also it was the year of the Tanzania
and Kenya bombings by Al Qaeda so she
was looking at these experiences and
seeing the debris from this and where
that was spreading to but she saw she
foresaw that it was coming for the
Muslims and she was right does the
parallels are clear in terms of the word
terrorist at that time I remember became
synonymous with Irish Republicans even
though loyalists were carrying out to
today at the word terrorist today is
synonymous with Muslims and jihad in
particular this concept so we are told
that we are because of these concepts in
our faith we are a terrorist community
or we are one that sympathized with
terrorism or we are a conveyor belt
terrorism or we are Trojan horses of
terrorism all these sorts of statements
are being put to us and what we hear
from a lot of the Irish Republican
prisons now who are part of the peace
process is they hate the word terrorism
they don't use it in their discussions
they don't even call the loyalists
terrorists they have all sorts of other
names for them but because this were
terrorists really and truly the most
famous man on the planet Nelson Mandela
is a convicted terrorist so what does
that do in terms of the uses of language
the Mujahideen in Afghanistan when they
were fighting against the Soviet Union
the Soviet Union called them terrorists
but the west and America in particular
after making films like Rambo 3 about
them lionized them and called them
freedom fighters so these terminologies
are not likely used in communities like
the the Irish community and they will
talk about legitimate struggle they will
talk about armed struggle and they were
talk about illegitimate struggle they
will talk about occupation forces and so
forth and their language will be
entirely different and then they will
talk about if you want to get to the end
of this problem they will talk about an
all-in
clusive dialogue which includes talking
to the most unpalatable sections of the
conflict and that is the lesson of
Northern Ireland it's the proof of that
is that you have Gerry Adams and Martin
McGuinness the the First Minister was
deputy first minister of Northern
Ireland who was an IRA leader so it
would be futile to use these types of
terms like terrorists it when you're
talking about a peace process you talk
to her lately when your first camp cage
prisoners building networks now one of
those networks was a networkable of
lawyers how do you go about building
those contacts you had or were they how
did you find the network of lawyers is
really important i think the lawyers
they're the life line between the
guantanamo prisoners and the free world
the lawyers despite the literate
ridiculous restrictions placed upon them
in terms of a client attorney privilege
that would not apply anywhere else on
earth and they've managed to do a quite
an amazing job in terms of getting the
cases of the prisoners out there and so
sometimes this is through personal
contact many of them even now will
personally contact me or other prisoners
and ask in relation to their clients and
what information we can give them or
they'll ask if we know anybody else who
could help them in relation to their
clients cases and of course several
people like Clive Stafford Smith are
themselves or almost a magnet of lawyers
and activism in relation to the
Guantanamo case but also the Center for
Constitutional Rights who first
represented me when I was in Guantanamo
and the American Civil Liberties Union
who are still fighting on the cases with
us so with all of these and the
independent lawyers the unsung heroes
often they do quite amazing jobs in
terms of trying to get the stories of of
the prisoners out some do it through the
legal process others do it through the
campaigning and political process all of
them I believe have been instrumental in
bringing the case of the Guantanamo
prisoners to
public for are you still in contact with
lawyers for cases down the Guantanamo
I'm constantly in contact with lawyers
constantly in contact with lawyers both
civilian lawyers military commissions
lawyers right across the board people
who don't agree with or believe in the
system but who are part of it and then
they've dealt been dealt the cards that
they have often contact me and other
prisoners to find a way any way out for
their clients and by no means to they
rely solely or even partially on the
legal process because they know that
doesn't work was there very internal
debate within cage business about the
direction of the organization in terms
of its going towards more as you said on
deal on join your involvement to the
move campaigning direction for you know
on the other hand taking more legalistic
approach was any was that was added
without a big subject of discussion or
was it we have discussed we've had many
discussions in terms of strategy and in
terms of remit also we have tended even
though there are three lawyers in cage
prisoners to cage presence hasn't taken
it as itself as an organization legal
actions I think there are plenty or and
enough organizations doing that and what
we do is support them in that so the
closest working relationships we have
our with for example reprieve and the
Center for Constitutional Rights with
Gareth peers and with other lawyers here
in the UK and and outside in the United
States of America we feel comfortable in
doing that we feel comfortable in being
at an information portal and conduit we
have the sources on the grounds like
nobody else does we know the prisoners
we know their families we are the
prisoners in fact several of the
prisoners are either working for cage
prisoners or a part of the advisory
board official advisor advisory board so
what we bring to the table is the people
themselves measure
working with the families why are some
of the problems we face with the
families and what kinds of resources do
you bring to help the families there are
some of the most acute cases in in terms
of for example there's one family whose
husband father has been disappeared in a
u.s. what we believe it was us prisoner
then it's now a Syrian prison that he
was handled by the u.s. to the Syrians
to a secret president and that family
has had no communication at all
whatsoever with their loved one that is
probably the most extreme case that we
have and what we try to do for them is
arranged or to get financial support get
contacts with members of the Syrian
human rights community with other human
rights organizations with embassies of
different countries and to help to find
and an investigate in fact we've been
involved in an F have actually located
this woman's loved one in a Syrian
prison and found exactly where he is and
sometimes that's done with great risk to
some of our workers and so our people
but we do it because we have a duty to
do it and also we have the ability to do
it in other cases there are families for
example whose loved ones are still in
Guantanamo and which we're trying to
either seek through the least
resettlement process with the help of
other organizations like Amnesty and
reprieve in the center of the
constitutional rights resettlement for
these people countries where they can go
back to or go to because of fear of
being tortured in their own rage in
their own countries the great thing
that's happened now that I again I'm
happy to have had some part in it is
helping to be involved in discussions
for resettlement of people who want to
go back to countries like Tunisia and
Egypt after the revolutions that have
happened there so some momentous things
are taking place in a great joy for
people who for example sentence in
absentia or feared torture for returning
to these countries now will be welcomed
back as heroes in a sense
closer to home there is an organization
our sister organization called hugs
which is helping households under great
stress and that is set up mostly by by
women and some young men to arrange
whether it's simple things like activity
days for children of parents who have
been held on the anti-terror legislation
or whether it's taking people to go and
visit their family members or taking
food to people who are unable to cook
for themselves and as suffering very
physical very practical issues
but for us as a campaign organization we
try to bring some hope through the
experiences of the individuals in cage
prisoners itself or that we're connected
to because that is the one thing that we
know from our experience is that once
that's gone it's real this little left
you have family therapy any any kind of
therapeutic at outreach for as cage
prisoners we don't have any therapy done
ourselves but we have close involvement
with the with the Helen bamboo
foundation for example who have worked
closely with the content of our
prisoners and others and the medical
foundation for the victims of torture we
worked closely with both organizations I
ask because in your book you said you
reached out to a psychotherapist well
yes it's true I I've reached out to
several therapists and I've been asked
by them to come and speak to them so
it's it's not that they're seeking
therapy for me but it's I think that
they are they're certainly trying to
learn and help I think in the way that
they can there was one particular
incident two incidents in Guantanamo
remember where a psychiatrist was
brought to me after I had an anxiety
attack and I remember one of the cases
this psychiatrist actually suggested a
method of suicide to me and asked me had
I ever thought about taking off my
trousers threading them with my sheet
tying the trouser Potter as a noose that
would fit around my neck tying it to the
corner of the cell and jumping off and I
said no it never crossed my mind until
she put the thought into my head so
there were all sorts of games being
played in Guantanamo by psychotherapists
to return the cage prisoners one of the
strike many striking things about the
organization is the great geographic
scope of some of the cases you're
involved with how do you manage that
school given you know that cage
prisoners is still fairly small
organization it's difficult the answer
had we manage all this the reality is
that we we don't manage it it manages
itself the people that are involved on
the ground managed themselves and they
seek assistance from us and we give them
that assistance so for example we have
people we work with closely in Pakistan
and in Kenya and in other places where
they take from our experience we take
from this it's a symbol a symbiotic
relationship we provide people who have
gone through the experiences of the
prisoners people who can give some
tangible links as to where they could go
next but in all essence the reality of
the prisoners situation is that it keeps
building it doesn't get smaller we I'd
thought always that well once this is
over I'm going to go into something
completely different but it doesn't seem
like there's an end there is this war on
terror and it's peripheries keep
continuing to keep opening up new doors
the detentions process for example i was
in Kenya just a few months ago under
what they call the new section of the
war on terror where it's it's linked
with Somali and so forth was happening
almost on a weekly basis people being
detained and rendered rendition is still
taking place and British intelligence
and American intelligence are still
involved on the ground and the same is
true in Pakistan of course so it doesn't
seem to me that this this is going to
end anytime shortly salut and my
schedule
listen I attended a seminar at ccr last
Tuesday where Geeta talked and she
raised exactly the issue you raised but
once this is over and her argument is
that I we have to recognize that this is
from a permanent state that is not a
temporary state that we have moved some
kind of a state of permanency with the
war on terror is that too bleak a
picture do you see some differently um I
think the reality is that President
Obama was was in that position to let us
know exactly what's going to happen next
and he's shown very very clearly I mean
unequivocally that the state of the war
on terror even though the term itself is
defunct take facto it's going on and it
will continue and it will expand and has
expanded and I think even when relation
to the Arab Spring we will see the war
on terror extend their once it settles
down one thing I realize although
Gaddafi and and and the Syrian regime
also both have used the al-qaeda specter
in an effort to try to deal ajith mais
these revolutions once I believe both
these countries in particular the
revolutions are successful we will see
the rise of Islamic parties as we've
seen Tunisia as we have seen in Egypt
and the West reluctance to engage with
or to recognize either of those groups
of people again if they don't do this
they will begin a new war on terror and
so I think this permanent state of
hostility
this permanent state of hostility is
going to remain as long as the attitudes
that allow them to persist remain why do
you think that the United States the UK
you you why do you think they're unable
to make that opening there are never let
them to make that opening because I
think they know very very well that the
psychology of the Arab and Muslim person
isn't as amnesiac as they would like it
to be so they know that for example when
the Iranian Revolution took place even
though it was a Shiite one Saddam
Hussein was backed and supported to
invade Iran and to kill millions of
Iranians as a result of their policy so
we know through history that whatever it
is that has the veneer of Islam on it
will be ready guarded as suspect and you
can see for example the refusal to
engage with the Muslim Brotherhood even
though they were the most legitimate
opera opposition group during Hosni
Mubarak's time has only festered a
dislike for the United States you can
ask anybody in Egypt from the
Brotherhood they do not like the United
States it doesn't mean they want to be a
state at a state of war with them but
they have a memory they remember what
happened they remember that Mubarak was
supported by the Americans in the West
at a time when their members were thrown
into prison and tortured and beaten to
death in some cases even though the
Brotherhood didn't take up the violent
methodology of the other Islamic groups
they still will remember that they were
left and they and these regimes were
backed by by by the West so Tony Blair
and the West in general had made their
peace with Gaddafi after he'd said that
he will no longer be part of the nuclear
arms race he was the new boy on the
block again he was being greeted by the
West and you can see that the father the
cannon fodder in all of this were these
Libyan dissidents people who had opposed
him they were from the Islamic movements
but they were solely involved in
opposing Gaddafi and removing him so
these people became the pawns in this
game and were put on control all those
financial sanctions and detained without
child in some cases and now those same
people i have met them in libya these
same people who had detained in the UK
and now in libya supported by british
forces supported by british aircraft
fighting against the Gaddafi regime so
these people they won't forget they know
that there are interests that it's in
their interest to be protected by
American and British bombs and they
welcome that but there are no friends of
the west and one thing also is known in
in Libya is that parts of the East
produced some of the people who went to
fight in Iraq and Afghanistan so and all
of this is in the psyche of the people
that's why you can see on the streets of
Libya in Benghazi it says in in Arabic
you'll seat and in English it says no to
al-qaeda and it says no to foreign
troops we don't want either I believe
you recently in Benghazi could you talk
a little bit about the experience in
that trip and being there in this time
this time of great turmoil and unchanged
I went to Egypt recently with a view to
visit Libya on my way I met with several
former Guantanamo a few former
Guantanamo prisoners a few former
Brotherhood prisoners and really that
the purpose of it was primarily the case
of ignore Schaffer Libby and he was a
Libyan man who I'd been held with around
the same time who was at the time in
2001 in Bagram it was said that he was
the most senior al Qaeda captive to date
when the CIA interrogated me and
threatened to send me to Egypt in Bagram
they said that if you don't cooperate
with us we'll do to you what we did to
it now shaker Libby and what they told
me they did to him was that they sent
him to Egypt and I thought
were bluffing at the time and later when
I was released I realized the hope the
case of ignore shake was huge that had
been sent to Egypt that he was tortured
under the auspices of Omar Suleiman who
is now in the house arrest but during
that torture he confessed to working
with Saddam Hussein on obtaining weapons
of mass destruction to kill Americans
and that statement was used by Colin
Powell in 2003 to try to justify a case
of war in Iraq ignore shake statement
was accepted a year later as a
fabrication he was then after being sent
to a series of Eastern European prisons
and elsewhere sent to the one place
where he feared the most Libya because
he was a Libyan and there he remained
until two thousand eight in May when he
allegedly turned up in his prison cell
dead because of hanging himself I met
with two prisoners in Benghazi who had
spent the last years of their life with
him the last days of their life of his
life with him and they both told me
quite categorically one of them is a
former Guantanamo prisoner the other had
been held in Gaddafi's prisons for 22
years and both told me that it was not a
suicide that he had been either killed
directly or as a result of neglect that
was something he suffered after having
razor blade / de Kock rests his chest
and his body and being left to bleed for
ages and apparently contact contracting
some blood diseases and and becoming
weak and dying in a state what was
interesting they told me that he was
being interrogated in Libyan custody by
us intelligence until the last days of
his death and so this and recognizing
how bizarre history and these events are
that this man who'd served in prison for
22 years for being an opponent of
Gaddafi was now seemed to be one of the
spiritual heads of the movement
supported by America
from a back that back to cage prisoners
how much is the organization how many
people work here how is the structure a
case prison is a relatively small
organization this is our first major
office that we have here in in London we
have I think now we've just taken on one
person for full-time workers four and a
half full time workers one person part
time works on the Arabic section and we
have myself as a director are some
croatia as an exit executive director we
have the Guantanamo expert Andy
Worthington who's just left the
organization now and we have another
former Guantanamo prisoner and a firm at
former a control audit detainee as well
as other interns who have their
specialist fields working in our
organization what's really amazing about
it is that we attract a lot of people a
lot of people from the human rights
community who want to be involved I want
to do internships in our organization as
we've had several Americans non-muslims
who produced some quite amazing work for
us and so the organization in that sense
I think it punches above its weight
category and in terms of the structure
we have we have a board we have our
patrons and they include Tory Britain
and then move on Ridley and Lauren booth
who's Tony Blair's sister-in-law I think
it's so funny and we sami al-hajj also
the former Guantanamo prison and al
Jazeera and cameramen and we are
constantly receiving support from all
walks of life we are constantly being
attacked it must be said in the media
and in the right-wing press in
particular for our associations or our
links with people who are regarded as
terrorism suspects and Frau defending
their rights and fighting for them and
advocating for them and
it's true we tread on eggshells
sometimes we produce work that people
don't like to see you don't like to hear
but that's I think where we gain a great
deal of our legitimacy in terms of the
people we were present could you talk a
little bit about me obviously one of the
major cases that's been brought up in
the right-wing press not too long ago
was your supposed association with a low
key could you talk about what we said of
you and how you responded to that um my
first my first encounter with our Lackey
was a radio interview I did him did with
him over the telephone shortly after his
release from a prison cell in Yemen he
made it clear that there were things
that he didn't want to talk about when I
asked him about his treatment and what
had actually happened to him in terms of
any abuses it is my personal belief
after having read and heard from people
what they said of him and that he was
hugely popular in the english-speaking
world and it's really important just to
get this point clarified because oh
lucky isn't hugely popular in the
arabic-speaking world because he's
relatively young and in the
arabic-speaking world there are scholars
of much higher standing than Awlaki and
so this is again something we do in the
West if he speaks English he's got to be
big the reality he isn't in the Arab
world there are much bigger people than
him the suggestion for example that he
will now take al Qaeda's leadership has
only been happening in the
english-speaking world it has not been
happening in the arabic-speaking world
and so yes we have this American dual
citizen those Yemeni who at one point
condemned openly the Twin Towers
attacked who was cleared by security in
the united states to visit the pentagon
and all of these things has now all of a
sudden done a u-turn when does he do it
he does it straight after his
interrogation in which he says that
American intelligence were present what
happened there what transpired what is
it that made him say those things I
don't know because when I interviewed
him he hadn't really taken a really
radical position or more of the lib and
all those people Nidal Hasan had not
those cases not come to the fore at the
time our campaigning for him therefore
it was as somebody who'd been detained
somebody who had been a prominent figure
and somebody who had the US war on
terror mechanism affect him we
campaigned for him even more now so in
the sense that he is somebody who's been
targeted for assassination by the US
President and we see that as something
extrajudicial we would have had a
campaign for some bin Laden had he been
detained and we would have fought for
his rights to just as we have fought for
the rights of other or Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed and we make no apologies about
that and that is because we believe and
I believe that anybody who stands
accused of crimes has to have its day in
court and I don't think that's too much
to ask for anybody considering that we
are nations of people who gave those
rights to people who committed much
greater atrocities at the end of the
Second World War and we're even
attempting now to give them two radko
bladedge slobodan milosevic in the past
and others and I was in Bosnia when
these things happened and I know that
these massacres were on a massive scale
in comparison to what these people stand
accused of
I was going to ask you about what your
reaction would have been two larges
arrests I'm glad you touched on it
because as you say it does beg the
comparison with this other aspect of
your work which is on extrajudicial
killings but if I'm a tail back to what
cage prisoners is doing in Pakistan
could you talk a little bit more about
the part of the Pakistan project and the
question of the disappearances versus
dealing with detentions just when you
when you're working on these on the
grain of these different cases what are
the differences clearly what you can see
is that Pakistan was never a country
that was known for its human rights oh
it's great development or anything but
something that wasn't known in Pakistan
was disappearance people didn't
disappear in Pakistan they would perhaps
be kidnapped for ransom by some northern
tribes woman returned but there was
nothing in terms of state-sponsored
disappearances it didn't happen until
the war on terror began until the United
States gave the green light to Musharraf
and others to begin this policy so what
we've had in essence and I know because
I was disappeared during that time for a
period i was actually disappeared nobody
knew where I was other than the people
who takin me the fact that a state did
it doesn't mean it's any less
reprehensible in fact it's worse we work
closely with the defense for human
rights and I'm in a message on yahoo
herself is suffering the great trouble
having her own her husband disappeared
and she has lodged numerous cases in the
Pakistan courts and fought and
campaigned and single-handedly tried to
bring all of these cases in together
whether it's the Pakistan is held in
Bagram whereas the Pakistan is held in
Guantanamo or whether it's the ones that
have been disappeared the war on terror
or Berluti nationalists doesn't really
matter for her so we have a joint
working relationship with the defense
for human rights group and regularly
updated by them and regularly try to
place pressure on the US
on the Pakistani government through the
testimony of individuals that we have in
order that we can have at least these
people recognized at least they can
begin communication with their families
the fact that this has happened in
Pakistan because there are so many other
traumas taking place you know
subsequently in Pakistan it often seems
like Amina Masood and the little help
that we give her is fighting an uphill
battle all on her own but the one
amazing thing is that everybody in
Pakistan knows her she is a name that
you mention it to any Pakistani they
know the name and in that sense she has
done in a mazing job as a woman who's
suffering through this trauma not just
to be considered by the disappearance of
her own husband but to be considered by
the disappearances of other people and
that takes great strength do you think
this model of involvement with an
organization like hers in Pakistan could
be replicable to other countries and
other parts of the world say any staff
and floors yes III think so i think it's
possible um I think the dynamics are
slightly different in different places
but we've attempted to do something
similar in Kenya but Kenya has proved to
be a little more difficult in that even
the human rights workers who are not
even Muslims that have worked there on
these cases have sometimes being
deported either from Uganda or deported
from Kenya have been interrogated and
frightened by intelligence officers
operating there I spoke in the largest
mosque in East Africa to a congregation
of 12,000 people about standing up as a
community about fighting for the rights
of their own citizens about the ideas of
citizens of their country who have been
rendered and handed over to another
country to be interrogated by British
American intelligence officers and to
tell them that if they don't do this
then they could very easily be next and
that has been our experience here in the
UK where initially we found a great deal
of apathy and
here and now cage prisoners is is a
everybody knows cage prisoners in the
Muslim community and they know it
because what we said transpired is that
if you don't take the bull by the horns
now when they come for you in whatever
way they do whether it's schedule 7
airport stops or whether it's stop and
search or whether it's detention without
trial whether whether it's some
anti-terror legislation you'll have
nobody to blame but yourself if you
don't take a position now recognizing a
variety of the Muslim community in
Britain what are your relationships in
the community you mentioned everyone
recognizes that means somehow you you
have a pulse or you have some kind of
feeling for the community yeah and it's
important to say first of all that
Muslim community is not homogeneous it's
not one single monolithic community but
generally we can say that Jen and it's a
very general term broadly set the Muslim
community through various organizations
that seem to be in the public for speak
with us we talk together often we are
present at their invitations we are
recognized by them for the work we do
and and so even though before in the
past there was a great deal of fear cage
prisoners need to stay away from these
guys because they're terrorism related
stuff and we don't want to see our
funding cut by our association all that
sort of stuff does happen but there's no
escaping the message there's no escaping
what we're talking about there's no
escaping the experiences of the
Guantanamo prisoners or the UK prisoners
or detention without trial or control
orders there's no escaping any of this
is a reality and in the end you'll have
to somehow come and communicate with the
people who know about it like no one
else does I've work
number groups where that kind of
existential situation does not happen in
which the debate within the group is
always over the line but this kind of
strikes me that the situation on the
ground is is so radical itself that a
debate over the line is superfluous is
that fair that you're right it is the
debate of the line whatever it is it's
well beyond that and as far as cage
prison is concerned I think some people
would see us that our discussions are
beyond the line it's it's it's and we
will talk about things that other NGOs
won't talk about but will we feel that
were in a position to talk about these
things even if it's at the cost
sometimes of other organizations saying
but we don't really want to be
associated with you in this regard
they're not feeling it with the greatest
of respect to all of the organizations
and without wanting to seem to be
playing the victim card they're not
feeling it on a day-to-day basis they go
home and they sleep it off and it
doesn't mean anything we go home and
it's in our face we go home we expect
the doc on the door all of us do doesn't
matter who we are we see a police car
behind us we think it's coming for us
we're at the airport we get stopped we
get interrogated we get questioned and
so we can we do the work the people who
are affected by this attitude and
legislation here in cage prisoners do
the work in the organ organizations they
don't and that's not their fault
nobody's blaming them for it but some
there's a difference between something
that affects you directly personally and
that's something that is your job in
essence
in the in the current political and
discursive climate in the UK have you
considered have you have you thought any
political allies or do you find that in
the ambitions of the campaign of cage
prisoners what kind of mark can you make
on the political playing field yes we do
we constantly seek dialogue and
discussion with people in power and have
have been in discussions with ministers
of this government the last government
wasn't so easy but this government yes
we've been involved in at least as as
individuals discussions with ministers
senior ministers about different issues
we've been involved with people who are
reviewers of terrorism as as appointed
by the government we have put forward at
out our grievances and our recognition
of the situation and our analysis of the
situation we have engaged with
politicians who will engage with us we
have sought alliance with groups who
would seek alliance with us but we
haven't sort of done the bend over
backwards trying our best to accommodate
everybody simply to get into their good
books because we've seen so much of that
and in the end we feel that that type of
behavior simply undermines your own
credibility so we need to we try to
remain true to our goals and principles
we are not sectarian we are not a
primarily a religious organization we
have religious ethos in terms of being
Muslims but we're not a religious
proselytizing organization we believe in
the rule of law and we advocate for that
for all communities and for everyone and
if that is something that in terms of
how we do our job it is not it is not
what everybody wants to be involved with
we don't impose ourselves on anyone
and I'm a tree that it was it's easier
to work with this government than the
previous governments yeah my old lovely
background is why well as time in terms
of the politics then we would have said
of course that the more left-wing
government would be easy to work with
but of course the politics of New Labour
and the new government have changed so
much so it's almost unrecognizable the
politics of Tony Blair were more
right-wing than the right wing of today
and it's blurred it's very very blurred
the new government the discussions we've
had with the new government suggests at
least in word if not indeed that they
want to show themselves to be part of
the process that helps to rectify the
most unpopular war that's been around in
the history of Britain which showed that
British people marched over two million
I mean British people don't march in
great numbers for anything so the fact
that they did this shows it wasn't just
the Muslims getting radicalized it was
the entire nation but in addition to
this also they have attempted to engage
with some of us in terms of what's
happened to the abuses the abuses of the
Guantanamo prisoners the allegations of
British intelligence involved in the
torture of British citizens has been
extremely sensitive been it has shaken
the government I believe and our
engagement has been through the civil
legal process but also through the the
criminal process we're talking to the
police about actions of the British
intelligence so we are talking across
the board to a whole lot of people that
who probably wouldn't have before in the
past but you're you're politically at
political activities would be limited by
your charter there are certain things
politically that you cannot do is that's
right that's what we're not involved in
any campaigning for any organization or
any political party we're not affiliated
to any political party neither do we
take any position on any any groups that
are campaigning our simple work is our
roommate which is to campaign and fight
for the rights of the
people who have been detained without
charge or trial what people have been we
believe subjected to anti-terror
legislation that is not fitting for the
crime that they're accused of could you
what whea skull sit around the edges of
this issue but could you talk a little
bit maybe in detail about your reaction
to the news of Osama bin Laden's death
um well to be honest when I hear about
the death of any Muslim my personal
reaction is to save from Allah we came
in on tarlac we return and Allah will
deal with whoever he wishes however he
wishes of course of some bin Laden was
dealt with in this world and in this
world I believe there are rules and
regulations that are supposed to be
followed I cannot support what the
Americans have done because the
Americans took me in Islamabad with a
gun to my head in the middle of the
night in front of my family it was just
that movement that movement between me
and death so how could I support this
how could I say that it was okay for him
to do this okay for them to do this if
they believe he's in responsible crime
and why didn't they capture him and take
him and then the stories put out make it
even worse in terms of my how I
perceived this they said that his wife
was placed in front of him as a shield
which turned out to be a lie said that
he was armed that turned out to be alive
so all of the lies that have been put
forward contrast to the jubilation
clearly that is around available in
America in terms of the death of Osama
bin Laden I don't believe justice has
been done in any way shape or form with
his assassination and the only way to
describe it is the assassination of
Osama bin Laden along with of course the
other people were killed it's as if they
don't count these other people are
simply peripheral to shoot a person in
front of his child I was taken at
gunpoint in front of my children how
could I accept this for any
so my reaction is that osama bin laden
in the great scheme of things other than
symbol won't make a great deal of
difference the war on terror will
continue and the responses as we've seen
in Pakistan and Afghanistan over the
past week or two is that scores of
people have been killed is it worth it
is this the direction with which we want
to go in if they captured bin Laden and
prosecuted and showed that yes he really
did commit these crimes somehow or was
there something else hidden were there
things that they didn't want to be
materialized were there things like with
Saddam Hussein's case I believe that
would have come to the fore that at some
point somebody would have had to say who
supported him when he gassed the
Iranians is there that sort of
information that people don't want
coming out otherwise why would you allow
these sorts of things to take place so I
remain exceedingly exceedingly skeptical
it's quite different from the Nuremberg
example of an international tribunal
there there there is there's no
comparison at all in this this is an
extra douchey look killing this is this
is Obama Obama is the president of
extrajudicial killing as Bush was the
president of extrajudicial detention
when you look back on cage prisoners
what do you think your grass
achievements being so far
um our greatest achievement thus far
staying alive probably I think our
greatest achievement thus far has been
moving from an organization that was
obscure and nobody knew to a point that
it is now being mentioned by people in
power in the world who know it who have
seen its work and who I have presented
directly to some of the leaders of the
world and told that this organization
campaigns for people who are in the
world's most notorious prison and in
terms of achievement I think we can see
it in the the real tangible achievement
the responses we get from family members
from children from wives and people like
that who say that we are so pleased that
cage prisoners is fighting our course in
our case because nobody else is so that
to me is an achievement in that is help
to empower a community that has become
very frightened and very apprehensive
and that is one of our aims and
objectives conversely what would you
what would you feels your gravestone
greatest failure still have four people
working with the organization we should
have been much bigger by that I think
our greatest failure really probably has
been in being able to to take on the
cases all the cases that we should and
to campaign adequately for all the cases
that deserve our attention and not being
able to do so because of lack of
resource we're talking a few months ago
informally about your international
travels wonder if you can talk few more
minutes about that Libya Iran one of the
the recent visits I had in Libya had me
and under a group of people go and meet
with some former prisoners in a prison
in Benghazi
and they taught us around this prison
that had been captured now by the rebels
and it being burnt out and destroyed and
they took us into the interrogation
cells and one place they took me to was
a place where they told me that a a
woman who now lives in the UK a Libyan
woman had been abused and tortured and
they showed me the cell it was to walk
into it seemed very bizarre it seemed
like an ordinary place it seemed like a
house that had been birthed down it just
seemed very ordinary then they took me
into these holding cells and showed me
these rows of cells and ultimately the
block it reminded me of Guantanamo but
the difference was that these were
concrete structures and they were tiny
it was impossible for somebody as short
as me to actually physically lie down in
this cell I don't know how people could
have slept there except to curl up in a
fetal position and lie down in this in
this horrific cell and what was also
amazing is that people had they were
still drawings in there that had been
made by pencil Quranic verses that talk
about patients at the time of adversity
verses that spoke about the story of the
Prophet Joseph or Yusuf who was thrown
into prison according to the Bible and
the Quran for a crime that he didn't
commit there were also drawings of
freedom of trees of the sea of children
of cars that was still very visible and
all of the thoughts of your own
incarceration of course come rushing
back to your head but the people who
were telling me about this had
themselves
spent a great deal of time in this
prison and also in the prison that is
still as we speak run by Gaddafi in
Tripoli the prison where Edgar shakily
died abu salim prison whatever around
Iran I went for a conference recently
which was one to discuss a terrorism and
the concept of terrorism and during this
conference amongst other people we met
the present and I delivered a speech in
front of the president in which I talked
about the concept of terrorism and how
this term as had been explained by one
of my Irish friends who was also present
at the at the conference is one that
people shouldn't necessarily use simply
because it's being used in the West and
people need to come up with terms not
only just to accuse others of being this
but to try to deconstruct it and to see
a way forward because what we've seen
through the experience of quote-unquote
terrorism is that once you've labeled
somebody a terrorist it's very hard then
to start to get into an engagement with
them to talk to them to legitimize them
and this is the problem that I know that
the United States is facing in
Afghanistan for example with talking to
the Taliban well how can you talk to an
organization that is all but human it is
subhuman when then you try to humanize
people and I think one of the people who
did this even though he's the head of
the anti bin Laden unit at a time was
Michael sure who spoke about in his book
on Osama bin Laden he says that the
mistakes that the West has made is in
the failure to recognize for example
Osama's piety his integrity his personal
bravery his his egalitarian ISM and
things like this so if
you do that to your enemy even though
you want to capture and kill him and
sure says that we wanted to capture and
kill him then at least you've humanized
them then at least you're not talking
about an animal or a monster and that's
what's happened in the dehumanization
processes on both sides when we were
dehumanized it was done because of the
differences that people were told that
we had and therefore it was easy to
torture us but when you humanize
somebody it becomes much harder than to
do all the things that you do to them
and then it's easier if you humanize
them to also bring them into an
engagement process so that you can bring
an end to the conflict somehow you were
suggesting earlier essentially a
conceptual failure failure language how
does one go about changing that language
or incrementally even and this cage
prisoners have a role to play in that in
that task we often talk about language
we often talk about the use the misuse
and the manipulation of language for all
sorts of purposes and one of the things
we'll say for example the word terrorism
how did it ever enter the English
language and it came into the use of the
English language from Livan Tahoe which
is French for the Great Terror and that
was the revolution so as far as the
elite of Europe were concerned the
introduction of democracy in the UK in
Europe was terrorism it was the
beheading of the aristocrats and French
wrote the revolution so and if you look
at the new american heritage dictionary
you'll see that the word terrorism is
used to describe individuals and
organizations but doesn't mention states
whereas previous ones mentioned states
are involved in terrorism or can be
involved in terrorism so we think that
the redefining of language or by
interested sources is something we need
to challenge inand the greatest example
for us as Muslims is the word jihad and
you can see now you can go to the
average American and he will say jihad
is terrorism anybody who believes in Jed
is
terrorists and we won't say that we'll
have this argument to say well jihad
only means the internal spiritual
struggle in it doesn't mean that it
means so many things but the greatest
evidence of the hypocrisy and the
manipulation of language isn't itself as
to how the West in particular the United
States has dealt with this issue so you
can see Mujahideen during the 80s was a
word that was synonymous with the people
who fought against the Soviet Union and
they were glorified they were given
stinger anti-aircraft weapons and
presidents would descend into Pakistan
and try to meet with the tribesmen there
and yet today the words you had does not
it's as if that whole period didn't
exist so it's very difficult for us as a
community to try to take this on when we
think there's a concept of of the
self-defense that is a no will do within
the Muslim faith has now become
demonized because of the use and the
manipulation of language somebody can
say that person is a jihadist that's an
Arabic word that has an English suffix
doesn't make any sense
one of them in beyond language I know
that you you have you written poetry as
well and why I think on the kid
prisoners website one of the one of
amongst you know the many things that
people can do there's the suggestion
that that writing poetry and writing
writing and creating artists in avenue
and i know i think believe we recently
were judging a writing award could you
talk a little bit about poetry what it
did for you yeah it's just a word also
to be set up on artists that cage
prisoners did in 2008 an art exhibition
called Kate it was called interned the
art of the imprisoned and this was
something that was primarily done by
prisoners here in the UK prisoners held
on extradition deportation and control
orders and it was amazing artwork that
they produced they'd made mosques and
ships and boxes and jewelry boxes out of
little matchsticks in prison and it also
that this sort of reminded me of some of
the things that I'd seen in the Northern
Ireland prison museums people who wanted
to preserve some of the heritage of
their story of prison they were pottery
there was pottery beautiful pots plant
pots and earns made by the prisoners and
it showed a side of these people that of
course people that the authorities don't
want you to see that they can create
that they can think that they have
families behind that they have made
these things for their loved ones they
haven't made it for the exhibition they
made it for their loved ones and they
have a heart and that heart is broken
because of the situation that they're
put in and their children's hearts are
broken and their letters and their poems
have all been displayed in this
exhibition and so some of my own poetry
and other people's poetry was also
displayed and for me poetry was
something that helped
to not just give my voice to the people
I wanted to hear it but to myself also
I'm talking to myself I'm talking I'm
having a conversation with myself as
crazy at that may sound but I understand
me and also I wanted my captives to see
it I knew that when I'd send these poems
who would have to go through censorship
and in this small chance that the person
who's censoring these poems might even
understand a little bit of it it was
worth the effort after I think that's a
nice place to start the small chance
that someone in the future will see this
as part of the conversation thank you
very much
you